Alright guys, so in this lecture, I'm going to teach you how I personally use Autoflow Trading
Strategy from A to Z, what I look for and all, okay. So this is my personal method. The matter
that I've taught you before, it works as well, but this is a little bit different how I approach it,
okay. So first of all, as you know me, I like to stick with higher time frames. So first of all,
I would go to the 4 hour time frame or daily, okay. So let's suppose I'm looking at your USD.
So for Autoflow, what I like to do is use your USD, GPU USD and AUD USD because I like to,
you know, combine DXY and these pairs together to find Autoflow trades and I'm going to explain
that later in the video. So if I'm on the 4 hour time frame and the market structure is
bullish, right, I'm only going to look for, you know, long positions, okay. And I want a clear
trending market, I do not want one consolidation, something like that, okay. No, I want like a clear
perfect trend. So what happens is when you are on a 4 hour time frame, you're going to have,
so let's say you have a new break of structure, right. So this right here is a new break of
structure. There is going to be an auto block and for, you know, when I'm on a higher time frame
and also for the auto flow strategy, I use the auto blocks, the last bearish candle before
move to the upside or consecutive bearish candles before move to the upside. I have made a video
about auto blocks on my YouTube, you can go and watch it. That type of auto blocks I use for
this strategy, specifically only, okay. So what I'm going to do is going to patiently wait for
price to come back into that auto block. Okay. And when that happens, wait, yep. When that happens,
I'm going to drop down to 15 minute timeframe. And I'm simply going to look for market structure
shift entry during kills on ours and boom. That is absolutely it guys. No need to complicate it.
Okay. And I will give you examples and it's going to be clear to you, but let me show you another
bearish diagram. So let's assume that you have a bearish trend. And you have consecutive bullish
candles before move to the downside. So you mark that out the body of the candle. Okay, you're
going to watch, you have to watch that video on YouTube. And then you're going to know what
I'm talking about. So when price comes back, right, you drop down to 15 minute, you look for market
structure shift. Okay. And once you have like market structure shift, you take your entry
from that last bullish candle that is going to be here, the body of the candle. Okay. Or you could
use consecutive bullish candles. So I will give you an example. I'll give you a couple of examples,
and it's going to be clear what I'm talking about. So the very first rule is identify
high timeframe market structure. Price action has to be in a solid trending position. Okay. It has
to trend. Okay. It does not need to be consolidating. No, we do not want that. Because when price is
consolidating, that is the condition where there's going to be a lot of liquidity sweeps. So even
though your buys or your prediction about the trend is accurate, it's going to stop you out most
of the time. So just see, guys, Forex is the game of patience. If a guy is good with his psychology,
and it has, and it has some sort of patience, he's going to just kill these markets. Whereas a
person who has like the best strategy in the world, but his psychology is shit, he's going to lose
money. Trust me. Okay. Because when I studied ICT back in like 2018 and 17, I was a student.
And I knew what I was doing, but my psychology was so bad, guys, like I literally would over risk
revenge trade and all. So don't do that. Okay. I'm just saying these things because so you don't
have to go through those things again. So in a solid training position, we have that perfect
wait for your break of structure. And also, let me point this out. The autoblock that is right here,
right? It could be here as well, too. And it means any autoblock above the 0.5 level. Okay.
You just have to look for confirmation entry. So let's say there is a bullish,
yeah, if there's a bullish candle right here, some around here, right, you wait for price to come
back here. Let me do that. Okay. So you wait for price to come back into the autoblock,
look for market structure shift. And if it gives you market structure shift or confirmation entry,
take that trade. Okay. Simple as that.
And what I sometimes like is when I'm on the phone all the time from, right? And there's autoblock
here. I want to see some sort of a little bit of consolidation here, guys, like if you have the
patience to look for this, right? And then price goes back into your PI, look for confirmation entry
and boom. Okay. So here, guys, let me give you guys a couple of examples, and that is going to be
clear for you.